the penguin anthology of 20 20th century
American poetry is it's a Gargan it's a
gargantuan project and basically I'm
trying to make sense poetically of the
20th century in America so it starts
really right there with Edgar Arlington
Robinson and it goes up until anything
published year 2000 I'm try so what the
difference in this anthology is instead
of just a poem here um there are two
poems like this person trying to give a
sense of of major poets who then
influenced other poets as well so there
we may be quite a few poems by say let's
choose someone William Carlos Williams
and then show how he influenced all
sorts of other poets who may have a few
other not as many problems in an
anthology what makes a classic poem I
think that when a poem can move
readers across generations and across
its specific class or race then it
becomes truly classic I mean in other
words if the poem is so moving that even
if you have no experience in that
particular setting be it 1920s harlem
let's say you still are so moved that
that that you can put yourself in that
position that means that the writer has
managed to go beyond the the personal
and and and touch the humanity in all of
us and it's been it's really a blast to
read it because I realized how that this
does hold true for the truly great poems
oh gosh no there's not a specific poem
there there it changes it changes
depending on the on the um what I'm
working with where I'm at at the moment
but there are I mean they're just poems
that are just so amazing to me and I and
if I name one that I'd of course lose
another but but it it goes in and out I
think that can you think I can't name a
specific one lines flow through my head
there's a a very beautiful German poem
by Goethe which I often say to myself
because it's like a little prayer and uh
but it's also totally untranslatable
I've never been able to to translate it
and it's humbling because you realize
that we need translators please please
please we need our translators otherwise
we'll never have any of these poles we
would never know who how bottle air
moves us or anything like that but you
also realize how much gets lost about
how necessarily poetry is sold bonded to
the to the language in which it is
composed that it's you you're always
going to lose something and I find that
very humbling um so yeah but it's a
wonderful illuminant Rhymes but it
rhymes in odd ways
booberella gipfel hears truth and olive
Ibsen spirits do come and how Vartan wah
Banda who was throughout that's it you
can hear the rhymes and basically
transfer it says over all the mountains
tranquility
rests in all of the tips of the trees
and that's VIP phone which is a great
border all the tops of the trees you can
you can hardly feel a breath wait just
wait
soon you too will rest and it's just
it's because of the rise that makes and
here's such a calm home and it's just in
certain words are totally untranslatable
like VIP phone which does mean tips of
the trees but that doesn't sound very
good in English
but it's it almost walks you to sleep
and I just find it an incredibly amazing
poem for its tightness